Tomemos el número 7 y vamos a dividirlo entre 3, y
vamos a conceptualizar la idea de dividir entre 3
como la cantidad de grupos de 3 que podemos formar
a partir de 7 cosas. Así que dibujemos 7 cosas: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 y 7. Ahora intentemos crear grupos
de 3, efectivamente, podemos crear un grupo de 3
por aquí y también podemos crear otro grupo de
3 por acá, así que podemos crear 2 grupos de 3,
y luego ya no podemos crear más grupos completos
de 3. Básicamente sobra esta cosa de aquí,
así que este es nuestro residuo, es
lo que queda después de crear tantos
grupos de 3 como pudimos. Entonces, al ver esta
división, las personas suelen responder "Bueno,
podemos crear 2 grupos de 3, pero la división
no es exacta o 3 no divide exactamente a 7,
entonces terminamos con un sobrante ya que
tenemos un residuo de 1". Así que literalmente,
lo que tenemos es 7 ÷ 3 = 2 con un residuo de 1,
y esto tiene sentido porque 2 x 3 es 6, así que no
llegamos hasta 7, pero si tenemos un residuo de 1,
entonces 6 más el residuo de 1 nos da exactamente
7. Bien, hagamos otra división. Pensemos en 15 ÷
4, así que dibujemos 15 objetos: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14 y 15. Ahora vamos a
dividirlos en grupos de 4: tenemos un grupo de 4,
otro grupo de cuatro y otro grupo de 4; así que
podemos crear 3 grupos de 4 y ya no podemos crear
un cuarto grupo completo de 4, por lo tanto,
tenemos este residuo, tenemos un residuo de 3,
nos sobran 3. Entonces podemos decir que 15 ÷ 4
= 3 con un residuo de 3; 4 cabe 3 veces en 15,
pero eso sólo nos lleva hasta 12, 4 x 3 es
12, para llegar a 15 necesitamos usar nuestro
residuo, necesitamos 3 más, así que cuando
dividimos 15 ÷ 4 tenemos un residuo de 3.